we are on problem 17
problem 17.
alice and karen stand back to back they
each take 10 steps in opposite
directions away from each other and stop
alice then turns around walks towards
corinne and reaches her in 17 steps okay
so this is interesting
so
they're back to back alice let's say
alice goes this way let's say a is for
alice step so 10 alice steps
we don't know how long alice steps are
and
and then you korean had gone this way
and taken ten corrin steps right c is
you know i don't know how long she takes
per step two feet who knows that's but c
is the distance of current steps in my
little world right here
okay so they took 10 steps in opposite
directions from each other and stopped
allison turns around and walks towards
corinne and reaches her in 17 steps so
this is where karen is now right
so this whole distance this whole
distance here
is 17 alice steps
17 alice steps
the length of one of alice steps is how
many times the length of one of karin's
steps and they say all of alice's steps
are the same length and all current
steps are the same length
well we know a couple of things we know
to get to here
would have been 10 alice steps right
this would have been 10
10 alice steps
so essentially
in the same distance that corrine took
10 steps alice took what she took seven
steps right she took 10 to get to the
middle and then seven more to get to
where corinne is so this is seven alice
steps
so seven times alice step length is
equal to 10 times corrin's step length
right i'm just saying 7a is equal to 10c
and what do we want to know we want to
know
the length of one of alice's steps is
how many times the length of one of
korean steps we want to solve for a so
alice's step is equal divide both sides
by 7 is equal to 10
over 7 times the current step and that's
our answer 10 over 7
next problem
problem 18.
let the function f be defined by
f of x
is equal to
x squared
plus 18.
if m is a positive number such that
f of 2m
is equal to
f of m
what is the value of m so let's just
don't you know a lot of people get
intimidated these function problems but
in some ways they're kind of the most
straightforward problems you just have
to sit and evaluate them so what's f of
2m so everywhere we see an x we put a 2m
so it's 2m squared
plus 18
right whoever saw an x i put a 2m and
that equals 2 times f of m
so wherever i see an x i put an amp so
that's m squared
plus 18.
now i just simplify 2m squared that's
equal to 4m squared plus 18
is equal to
m squared
plus 36. i just distributed the 2.
so you subtract 2m squared from both
sides you get 2 m squared plus 18 is
equal to 36. i subtracted this from both
sides subtract 18 from both sides you
get 2 m squared is equal to 18. divide
both sides by two you get m squared is
equal to
nine
and then you get
m
is equal to if you just did this
straight up you'd get plus or minus
three but they tell us that m is a
positive number so we know that m is
equal to 3
and we are done
and that's it i'll see you in the in the
next section